[Music]
hi everybody and welcome to the very
first
in our series of pi data global sponsor
interviews
thank you for joining us today for those
of you who don't know me i'm james
powell
i serve as the co-chair of the num focus
board of directors
i also serve as vice president with
purview over all pi data activity
it's been my absolute pleasure having
the opportunity
to volunteer in this capacity to help
them focus grow to help pi data grow
and to help the open source scientific
computing ecosystem grow
i think open source is fantastic i think
it's the key to innovation
and i think it's the key to producing
high quality
robust good work it's my pleasure today
to introduce to you paolo martinez from
metrostar
paolo would you like to tell everybody a
little bit about yourself
sure thing thanks james uh hello
everyone
my name is paolo martinez i'm a data
scientist
at metrostar systems and um
an organizer for pi data dc um
i'm fairly new to data science
however i think i have benefited from
the open source community and being able
to really accelerate my learning
and just stay on top of the latest
developments
excited to be here so paulo can you
briefly describe for us what metrostar
does
yes metrostart is in uh government
consulting
which means that we we
have a bunch of uh we have a bunch of
techies and we
build a lot of tech but it's not our own
so
we go on to government contracts for
different
sorts of agencies for example
currently i'm i'm working with the us
department of agriculture's
national agricultural statistical survey
so it's like the census for
agriculture and we
figure out what they got going on and
then we make some recommendations for
how to make it better
and that almost always includes some
python
um some like rapid iterations of
prototypes and
demos of like what's possible to help
them like develop that vision
and then we help them actually like
build it ground it and make it work
paulo can you briefly explain the data
science stack that you use at metrostar
and what open source tools or components
or libraries you use and for what
purpose
sure thing i'll do my best so i think
you know we always start with conda for
installs for
our environment management certainly uh
pandas
numpy um psychic learn um
we also have been working with uh desk
um and jupiter hub
and i do actually
a fair bit of plotly as well we use
bouquet
to visualize our dashboards
so we've got a lot of it going on could
you tell us a little bit more about your
use of desk
yes so we've got some really exciting
things going on with desk
um we use them not only so i know
traditionally people uh
use it to distribute data um over
clusters
uh we have this interesting application
where we actually
figure out a way to distribute services
uh
across desk workers it's um
it's not traditional uh and you know
like we're still
uh putting final touches on it but it's
a new and exciting
way that we've figured out to distribute
uh models
actually like large models to each node
so you only have to load the model once
fantastic so paulo it sounds like
metrostar is really invested
in open source technologies tell us
what's the coolest thing
you've been able to build using python
and the pi data stack
so uh my favorite project i'm partial to
nlp natural language processing and my
latest and most favorite project that i
built was a
leighton durschleigh allocation um topic
modeler
so that's unsupervised topic modeling
and i found a fantastic article uh
showing you how to do it with pi ldaviz
jupiter notebooks psychic learn
and all those open source projects i was
able to
learn implement and successfully
use to build the coolest model
i have built to date so metrostar is a
big believer in open source
we all love open source but what's your
biggest pain point
when it comes to the use of open source
tools yes so our biggest pain point
when it comes to using open source tools
is probably
version management and environment
management um
so it's trying to figure out like uh you
know like what version of something you
should
download which one to use i'm a big
proponent of environment.yamls
some people on my team prefer
requirements.txt something that we've
got going on right now which is working
pretty well is we have a hosted uh
jupiter hub environment so everybody
gets to
spawn their own server which has like a
baseline environment that we all have
access to and then if you need to you
can do a pip install on the fly
and that seems to be working pretty well
for us does metrostar's use
of open source tools help it innovate
without question
if you're using open source tools you're
using innovative tools
um so it absolutely helps us innovate we
get to see
the innovations that our people are
bringing into i guess like the ecosystem
and we get to implement them in
innovative ways and then we get to
share it and like workshop it with our
community at pi data dc
how do you think metrostar's commitment
to open source technologies and
specifically those in the pi data stack
help it attract top talent yeah i think
it's actually crucial
because among
i guess like python uh developers among
you know like people working in data
uh i think there's a group of people who
have figured out
that you know like the innovation uh the
exciting new developments are happening
in the open source
community and those uh
those types of developers tend to seek
out companies
that not only allow that but have
understood
uh how to embrace it and making it
like a driving uh factor and i guess
like
the value proposition you know it's not
just that we're going to
you know like build you some code that's
going to run and it's going to work it's
that we're going to bring you
solutions that are uh you know like
have been vetted by like the entire
community and are going to mash
very well with a bunch of other super
exciting solutions that are out there
and will be highly relevant to you know
like the next wave of innovations that
are coming down through the open source
community
paulo i'm curious when you were first
considering whether or not to join
metrostar
in your current role did the company's
openness to
technologies like the pi data stack and
open source scientific computing in
general
did that make a difference to you it
absolutely made the difference
uh it was really important to me to
find a company that was gonna let me
experiment and like have an open uh i
guess like
open range to figure out like which
tools and solutions were gonna work best
it was important to me that they weren't
going to lock me into using this or that
licensed product or a piece of software
and
it served us well it's helped us stay
dynamic adaptable
and yeah paulo do you feel like
the well-supported ecosystem
of open source scientific computing
tools
such as the ones that we use in the pi
data stack do you feel like that is
accelerated your ability to deliver
real results at your company without
question
yeah i would absolutely say that it has
um
the fact that i can uh you know like
google around for like some solutions
i can check the forums i can you know
check
conda kind of forge install things find
the tutorials
uh get the documentation all of those
things
are incredible accelerators
i don't i think one of the most
important lessons i've learned about
coding in general is that
it's not always about how smart you may
be
um it's about how many smart ideas
you've been exposed to
so having that exposure and that ability
to see
all these brilliant solutions that are
in the open source community is
an invaluable resource as an
organization why is metrostar so
involved and so interested in becoming
more involved in the pi data community
uh two reasons
one because uh we want to give back
you know like we want to make the world
a better place and i remember what it's
like to be
an up-and-coming developer and not
knowing exactly how to get your bearings
and
the meetups and the pi data community
are uh like you know like irreplaceable
it's just fantastic to be able to
benefit from
that sort of advice and expertise and
also because we know that that's where
the state of the art is
you know like that's where you go to
find out about the latest and the
greatest developments and that's where
people will tell you
hey i like downloaded the super popular
thing or like i tried to implement the
super popular package and guess what
there's this big gotcha that nobody had
found out about until i tried this one
thing
wow let's all learn something like
really cool and new about
you know this particular package that
you never would have thought of without
it so
it's uh it's where it's happening uh i
guess that's where the scene's at and
we like to be there what would you tell
to a colleague to help
convince them to support pi data or num
focus in the way that metrostar has
what i would tell them is you're
actually going to get a lot
more out of it than you put in
now those are rather selfish motivations
so i would also tell them you know make
the world a better place
the pi data community it is an
educational community
um you go there people are going to
teach you something they're going to be
generous with their time
uh at some point you will benefit from
it
um you will be able to give back to
others you're also going to make
uh you know like incredible like
friendships and connections
and you are contributing to
like a community of movement of people
that are building
not just like something new not just
like better tools to do
this or that discipline better but i
firmly believe that the advancements in
uh
i guess like data technologies may very
well represent some sort of
uh paradigm shift to the world um
you know like comparable to perhaps what
the industrial revolution did
so you are helping
make that change better you're helping
it be more informed
more human more connected
we wouldn't want to do that so what are
you most excited about
personally about the upcoming pi data
global event
i'm excited to learn a bunch of cool
stuff that i haven't learned before
i'm excited to see a new projects new
ways of thinking about data and python
i'm excited to see what the community
looks like at a global scale
and yeah i'm just excited to participate
in like such a fantastic community
paolo tell me a little bit about your
experience
and background as an organizer of pi
data dc
sure thing so uh i
actually attended several meetups
back in nashville before i moved to the
dc area
and once i was here my very first pi
data dc meetup i attended as an
organizer
so pi data dc had actually gone
dormant which happens sometimes with pi
data chapters
uh you know like we'll organize a big
conference you know like sometimes
people uh get a little bit busy
fortunately uh hussein and i uh
knew the organizers we got in touch we
were able to
sort of reboot it for the virtual age
given that we're in a pandemic you know
there were no in-person meetings
so we were able to really take advantage
of
i guess like the quality of the
community and the commitment to
make this happen even though it was all
uncharted territory we had to figure out
how to make the event happen while
coordinating and executing everything
[Music]
virtually
[Music]
you